how are you doing today Mark uh you know
I'm usually up here talking mainly about
myself you know and I have shared about
my family you know what kind of family
upbringing I had you know I was like the
third generation you know but as I could
remember when I'm a small I was really
really young you know I used to go to my
grandmother's house and I used to see my
uncles and you know they'd be in there
ironing for about four or five hours
right during the top counter you know I
mean to be smoking weed and let me
asking my grandma for their guns back
and then they're dope back and you know
she would give it back to him she would
put it away every night you know every
night when they would come home they'd
stash their [__] and my grandmother knew
where all the stash spots were so she
used to get them bring them back and
give them to them you know I mean I
remember we used to be in front of my
grandmother's house and they used to
tell us once the lights went on we were
no longer allowed outside and we used to
go inside and like stated before
everybody slept on the floor you know
and I remember a couple of times when my
uncle and his homies would be in the
front you know I mean they were in the
front one time and my homegirl was out
there with them and she was right there
kicking it and uh she had went inside
the house to use the bathroom while
somebody had knocked on the door
she went to the door and she opened it
and there was a dude out there with a
12-gauge shotgun and he shot her right
in the face he shot her in the face when
he shot her in the face the door shut
well my cousin went and opened the door
she started screaming I mean she had
pallet holes all over her face her my
older homegirl's name is Patsy she had
him all over her face and after months
and months after she had came out of the
hospital
she would always be able to pull BBS out
of her face you know what I mean and my
homies were really upset about that they
had shot one of my homegirls and she was
one of my main homegirls her name was
Patty her brothers or sisters her mom
they were all from our hood you know so
it was a lot of family and orientated
stuff so when she had got shot she ran
to my grandmother's house she lived but
now she disfigured you know I hadn't
seen her maybe 20 years later
and it looked like she had a lot of acne
scars but what it was was those pallets
were still coming out of her face what
they were doing was her body was
rejecting them so they were coming out
of her face the following day the dudes
came back again in my auntie used to
have a a blue Volkswagen used to be
parked on the side of the house and I
guess my uncle was in there fixing the
radio and the guys laying off with them
doing the same shotgun and it was a big
[__] on the side of the car you know
she's driving around with a big old buck
shot on the side of her car you know and
everybody knew that where she lived and
who she was because that that car would
always be parked there there wasn't only
holes right there there was holes by the
ceiling hosed by the living room kitchen
you know and thank God my grandmother
grandfather had never got shot
you only want to dig a shot right there
where was my uncle both my uncles my
cousin got shot there I got shot a lot
of times there you know what I mean and
finally I guess the city got fed up
because my grandmother was there for so
long like 30 35 years in that house
maybe 40. and that's about two
generations three generations coming
through you know what I mean me and my
little brother were the last ones that
she actually took care of but she also
had one of my other aunts that was in
Metropolitan Hospital
she just went berserkles sometimes I
knew when I first met her that she
wasn't always there because she would
offer me cigarettes and I was only like
eight nine years old and I would tell
her anything I don't smoke you know what
I mean if Grandma catches and smoking oh
don't worry about him he'll come in my
room and smoke so he has to go in there
and smoke with her this is after I
learned how to smoke cigarettes With My
Father I remember she used to smoke
those parliaments and those were the
nasty cigarettes you think of but she
used to smoke uh the parties and she
used to go out dancing to nightclubs
with her home girl and they used to go
to this thing called uh I think it was
called uh shears or chandeliers or
something like that but it was a
it was a strip joint slash uh bar and
they had went with three of my homies
one time and they went over there and
they were partying and [__] as soon as
they were leaving the place a dude came
out of his car with a 22 rifle and he
shot everybody that was in the car and
shot him and he's five times the
passengers died because they said the
bullet hit his head went up threw his
heart down back through his legs his
lungs and came out the back and I was
like I didn't really believe that you
know then the 22 would do that much
damage but I remember reading back in
the days that when the monsters used to
take somebody down in Italy and stuff
they used to use a small caliber of
weapon because it didn't make too much
noise they would place it in the back of
the ear and they would shoot at one time
and the person was dead you know I mean
so you know I said I used to conjure
that up in my mind you know how am I
going to catch somebody slipping where
could I catch them slipping because you
know they had a lot of homies they
outnumbered us they might outnumber us
about a hundred a hundred more than us
and they were really active they were in
Pico Rivera they were around for a long
way around we went to war with them like
about [__] I say like 55 1955 56 and we
went all the way up to war with him
until night until the year 2009 or
something like that we're just going at
it killing each other left and right I
remember I got out of prison and I was
fresh out of prison I was small I was
swole and I go to my park and I see
dudes playing football and [__] you know
I mean I asked my homie hey who's that
you know and he tells me who it is and
I'm like what [__] that I take off my
[__] jacket my pullover I'm like I'm
gonna [__] one of these dudes up well as
soon as I got to where the guy was at my
homies intervened and they told me amen
if you touch this dude we're gonna have
to regulate you and I was like excuse me
I've never been regulated I never been
so excited I never been just smashed
beyond recognition but I have been
scolding in a very very strong Way by my
older homies because I used to be the
type of individual if I had a gun I'd be
showing it off cruising around everyone
according to that people shooting at
people you know we cruised up on the
side of a car one time and I was going
to get this guy we wanted him bad I was
going to get him and his old lady sits
up right in front of the barrel and I'm
like I'm young so I'm saying well [__]
her I'll shoot her too so I went to
shoot boom missed her end up hitting the
other dude well they started coming to
my house every weekend every weekend
they would come like clockwork you know
I mean these dudes were so [__] these
dudes had balls because what they would
do is they would park down the street
and they would walk to my home stand in
the front four or five of them and just
like the whole house up this house child
has that I had so many bullets on it and
so many shootings and stuff that the
city was trying to buy my grandmother
out they were trying to buy her out for
like 10 20 years and they couldn't get
her out because right after that uh
uncle came along came along my Uncle
Charles I don't want to say their full
names but now my Uncle Charles he was a
straight fool he taught me and my little
brothers and my cousins everything we
knew he used to wake up in the morning
with him eat breakfast he had a homemade
pull-up bar that he had made out of cast
iron we used to do pull-ups on that
every morning smoke a little bit of Bud
do some work more weights in the morning
and we figure I'm a young man I ain't
gonna blow up he'd be some big old hog
but I was getting a little healthy and
when I noticed the first time I went to
juvenile hall
you know there's no mandatory workout or
anything like that but you have so much
time on your hands you're in there 23
hours a day the only time you come out
is for TV break which is 45 minutes and
then a smoke break where you can smoke
you know what I mean I've been a lot of
places a lot of programs but the main
program that state that was boys
republic
and Scudder now cam Scutter stuck out
because everybody's ever getting related
and right down the way they have all the
women gaming at it so if we did good the
women would come and kick it with us and
we'd get to swim with them you know do
dirty things to them under the water you
know being get close to them and the
staff didn't really matter so that was
my first stop Camp you know I mean it
was then it was I was at Camp I get out
into the streets and now my cousin
Rudy's there Rudy's about two years
older than me and this guy has some sick
ass hands I'm talking about he puts easy
from the hip and straight knocks you out
I've seen it do it to several people but
why don't I mentioned one time we're in
Chino and they're telling me hey Johnny
your cousin got together regulation man
I told him look
yourself a favor and don't send those
guys in there with them because those
guys are going to get hurt well then
believing that my cousin wasn't [__]
he's standing on like all that big you
don't work out that he was gonna put
hands on him so what they did was they
sent him in the TV room they shut the
door and then when it's time to come out
they knock they let them back out well
my cousin went in there and I'm telling
the dude man you shouldn't have sent him
in there now I'm hearing boom boom boom
boom [__] falling people falling all
that [__] about a couple of minutes
later
my my cousins comes out the door you
know all the dudes are laying on the
floor and I told the dude that was
running [__] I said I told you man I'm
not here to shoot hot up here up your
ass because I don't shoot hot air up
there in anybody's ass you don't like I
ran into a gentleman yesterday instead
he said that he did an interview and
then he kind of went by the stuff that I
had said because of the fact that he
really didn't know me but when he did
his homework he had found out okay this
is what's up with Johnny he [__] with
him he'll make you disappear that was
just the way it was I didn't mean around
the bushes with nobody it was like I
didn't want to go snatch anybody up from
their house so I used to think of a
better way you know like this girl like
my homie hey take it over here down into
to the arcade place and when you guys
come out I'll [__] put some bullets
in this [__] you know I mean just on GP
you know because a lot of them were in
my hood and they were slinging dope and
they were making big money Mark big
money I'm talking about stacks of paper
man and I had this one homie that he was
cut can use in the spark spark plug
bottles the whole thing now the price I
couldn't even give you because one of
those black vials the fast the fat small
ones those are 500 that you pay for that
not a little cigarettes the Rolling
Papers because you can't just dip a
cigarette bring it out and smoke it
reason because it's real flammable it'll
blow up in your face many times I dipped
one forgot to get another cigarette and
use that as as a starter but my homies a
couple times didn't use it as starter
and one of them had their whole finger
right here just peeled off how it peeled
off I'm thinking some type of acid or
grease he had inside inside the camera
froze his fingers and they look like
frost but they look if you can bend them
that they would snap and he was
constantly in pain you notice he tells
me hey Johnny these [__] dudes shot
my arm man I see him I can't get busy
with them one-on-one you know what's up
with we do in the favor I said yeah no
problem so we took a little cruise we
cruised up all through everybody's Hood
finally behold we caught this little
[__] dude walking down the street now
I know more or less what kind of attire
my homies wearing and what kind of
attire they were they were just for the
simple colors but we won't wear green
but on their shirt they have three palm
trees that represented Lester
Palmas that's what it represented now I
know my dad was at war with him because
my dad used to tell me stories about
these guys he used to mention their last
name and then he used to say hey I'm
going to go over there get a boy I'm
gonna go [__] this dude up and we'll go
I'll be in my car eating while my dad's
whooping somebody's ass and he's not
just whooping one motherfucker's ass
he's whipping the dude the dude that was
with him the guy that was over here with
him he whoop on everybody you know what
I mean and and I tripped out because I
never screamed I never got scared I
never uh whenever I seen somebody get
stabbed or somebody gets shot but it
doesn't really it doesn't really uh
excite me and I was wondering why I was
that the only was I destined to go to
war or or fight a big battle because
every battle that I'm in that I have
dreams of I'm on the front line and yeah
I got a few of my cousins a few of my
homies but I also got a few of my other
homies that are down the way in this
line I know that was so long but you can
see everybody's face you can talk to
them and everything and also remember
that there was this bright light
that sat up on top I wanted to look at
it or something inside my head said
don't look upon that don't even try and
peek at it I think to tell you the truth
that there was corpses inside there
that's what I was thinking because I'm
thinking just a week ago you opened up
the trunk and you had all kinds of candy
goodies and and hard liquor and
everything we took as much as we could
you only want he only wanted twenty
dollars for all that so we gave him the
twenty dollars not 10 minutes later he
comes back and my cousin had bought a
big old boom box the kind that used to
sound like they're like this big you
know they got a handle they got all the
buttons I remember I was sitting in the
rooms and I see somebody pick it up but
at that time I didn't know he was around
if I would have knew he was around he
wouldn't have picked up [__] he wouldn't
have been allowed inside inside the
driveway you know what I mean he used to
come amen go to the homies pad and pick
this up for me and I would tell them the
homie's not going to give it to me
because he knows darn well that I don't
use you know I mean those type of things
you know I mean just it's just not me so
it needs to get on me oh yeah homie you
need to get honest and say oh you guys
ain't doing [__] you guys ain't putting
no work these foods are coming shooting
the older homies and I was like wait up
pump your brakes you're telling me that
they're shooting the older homies but
yet you want me to stop you want me to
step up and put in the business you
these guys he did nothing to me you
don't mean maybe my homie gotten [__]
with one of them and then all war breaks
loose and I'm thinking in school all
these dudes are all my friends all my
homies and they're disrespecting my hood
and I'm wondering why in the [__] they
disrespecting my hood well when they
were doing that my homie took us to his
locker and he pulled down it must have
been a nine inch blade and he told me
look
carry this ain't even get out of hand
book their ass I'm like all right me
being a naive [__] that I am
again I take the knife with me and we're
going down the street we see these
[__] dudes in a mini truck and
they're throwing their gang signs we're
looking at them they're looking at us
and I tell my homie get on these
[__] he gets on them we hit the
freeway now the dude they hit the
freeway is easy one of the 5.0s the new
ones that came out the newest one that
came out I was like like 89.88 it was a
rock a right yeah a Roxy I think it was
Rockstar yeah something like that well
that car right there was really really
fast and I told him hey man let me use
your car who's around and find these
[__] then I'll come back and
get you we'll go over there we'll handle
business he was more like nah I ain't
gonna let my car out I don't want to let
my car last time I landed out listen
this happened and I'll tell them but
that's not my fault if the guy doesn't
bring back his stuff that you give to
him well shame on him when we catch him
we whoop his ass give him throw that ass
whooping and take everything he owns you
don't want to speak about that if
something pops into my head about Skid
Row you know what I've noticed about
Skid Row is you cannot leave anything
next to you without tiny to your wrist
or tiny to your foot or to your belt
buckles when someone pulls it you're
going to pull your whole body and you're
going to wake up you know that happened
to me like three separate occasions
the fourth thing that happened was I was
kicking it and I was running through a
Huntington Park and this lady walks up
to me I see Mark that she's pretty
tweeted out I see that she's been around
she knows what time it is and her old
man he didn't really even give a [__]
about her she would need to go do her do
and even just kick back and wait for her
to come back so he could spend you know
her money well
a lot of my homegirls at that time had
gone into Kukui dust the way they were
making Kukui dust was they got two jars
of pepper
a pickle jar who emptied out and to
throw all all the stuff in there then
they'll add the other [__] and then
they'll hook it up and it would get real
hard real hard not like a rock a little
bit harder but it wasn't the color of
rock it was like a purple like a
off-white and I was wondering you know
what the [__] are they putting inside
here that's making the the color of it
change I knew it wasn't me because of
the fact that I was in day out day out
in and out in and out I had no time to
sit there and lollygag with anybody
besides my grandmother the only reason
that these guys did was hurt with her
was because number one my grandmother
never ever repeat it what she had heard
regardless of who it was she never
admitted that I was out there gang
banging hurting people you know I mean
uh not just them but hurting their lives
I didn't realize this at first until you
know one of my homies got killed and he
was one of my good homies and I felt bad
I was shading tears and the same
question came to me hey why do you what
are you crying for and I would explain
to him what had happened that we went to
a wind chills we were over there kicking
it some dude walked in
he started talking [__] with my uncle
they took it outside my uncle went out
there another dude went out there and by
that time I got out there my uncle and
my and and my cousin my uncle and my my
other Uncle were snitched over a wall
they hadn't stabbed them and they'd put
them on top of a wall and they left them
right there nobody knew they were there
because it was in the back until I think
it was like on a Friday and they weren't
coming back till Monday so he sat in
there all Monday and I'm telling my
homies let's cut them down that's come
down you know because he's [__]
hanging and oh no I just leave him up
there you know he's like a decoration
I'm like you're cool you're a cold man a
decoration it's the man's life we're
talking about you know what I mean and
they didn't really care you know and
these days like with fentanyl you know
um before with Heroin if I had heroin
Mark and you were sick I would get you
well just on GP but nowadays I know
these dudes have fentanyl they ain't
trying to share with no one they ain't
trying to share with me you anybody in
general then they walk by Under talking
[__] on that Chris I got black you know
me I got this I got that one of my
little homies he's balling right now he
has a gang of guns a gang of cars you
know what I mean but he did it's a smart
way what he did was he didn't [__] with
nobody he didn't give nobody money he
didn't do no business with anybody he
didn't give nobody no fronts and that's
why he's up in the top right now living
in the loft you know he came at me with
a proposition and said hey come work for
me I told him I would but there's two
things wrong about that the first one is
the [__] scooter that you got to get
get way on is not like the scooter you
see today it's a big one these are real
small really really small and you can
hear them coming from a mile away
they're really fast you know what I mean
My Homie used to come down on his
motorcycle and he said Tom hey let me
check it out and he never ever wanted me
to use it never because he knew in the
back of my mind I was gonna cruise up
cruise right by him and leave it on let
him have it jump back on the bike and
we're gone you know I mean those those
are the type of plans that my homies
were giving me so I was using them as I
went along you know another time they
come to my house and they're looking for
my uncle and he's under the bed they're
turning all the beds over all the beds
over until I tell my wife and my cousin
ate lay on that bed
say you guys are pregnant and you won't
[__] with anyone [__] with you so you
know I mean they did that they went in
bed they didn't [__] with them but
half an hour 45 minutes before that they
would go in a mini truck and hide in the
back and they would call these Foods up
to the truck and you know us being men
if you treat beautiful women in a car
and they call you nine times out of ten
you're going there just luckily that
when I was going to be just accidentally
broke out of her window a little bit and
I see my shoes and I confront you know I
couldn't front it and you know hey you
know uh the reason I lost my shoe
because I had smoked some juice and it
was real real good juice and I always
had heard that PCP makes you take your
clothes off and I didn't believe that
[__] until I woke up the next day I had
[__] some other shoes on a pair of
shorts and a t-shirt and I was like this
is not what I came with what I came with
was my black Levi's the big ones my
black sweatshirt and my black Nikes I
don't know if I was asleep and they took
them when I was asleep but that's like
the number one thing here in Skid Row
everybody wants to touch everybody
else's [__] one of my homies that I was
dealing with he just barely got out I
explained to him about this and
everything he said he's going to come
he's a real good dude he has a lot of
stories I mean he has a lot of stories
and they're all true name the things you
hear from me or one of my homies it's
mainly true it's true because of the
fact that our fathers were homeboys and
they did the same thing so it was it too
hard for us to figure out
how to go about not even getting busted
because my uncle and my dad their thing
was they would tell me oh we don't ever
get busted we don't ever get busted Only
Fools get busted and I was like how is
that possible you guys are out here gang
banging hurting people stabbing people
back then they used to Bumper Jack
[__] you know what a bumper
Jack is it's that big ass Square pipe
you stick the bar in and you jack your
car up they used to hit guys with that I
remember they were hitting this dude so
many times that the dude wasn't even
moving groaning trying to block his face
nothing and they beat this dude so
[__] bad that sometimes it gives me
chills on my body because I don't see if
I could ever succumb to that I don't
know if I can see if I could succumb to
actually hurting someone and then
leaving them for dead if I think if I
hurt them I think I'll call 9-1-1 and
give them the information where he's at
because a lot of dudes running around
here Mark like they got a big old gun
and when it comes down to it they ain't
got [__] I had a [__] saying he
was gonna smoke me and when I caught
this little [__] I searched his pants
through his waist and everything he
didn't have [__] I made him take his
socks off he didn't have nothing no gun
no you know or you say he didn't have no
residue from the firearm but the only
way you could get that stuff up is if
you wear wrist High gloves and they
don't break you know right now I'm
getting into tattooing I want a tattoo
and put some work on the fellas that are
here so everybody could see what real
work is because I see a lot of work and
he'll get me wrong there's a lot of guy
out here that tattoo and they're not
very bad but they're not very good as
well you know what I mean either some
are mediocre unless I gotta get the New
York when I got to mix it with you know
maybe some sugar some candy and I'll
hook it up you know I mean the whole
thing the whole thing worked what I was
getting at right now was
when I stopped gang banging for a while
I wanted to go into business I was
selling something else instead of drugs
I tried to G rides the cars but what it
was with the cars is that we had to get
rid of them we would take them down to
the riverbed and light them on fire due
to the fact that when we had a car for
so long the other gang would recognize
who we were and before we got to the
block they were lighting us up in my
homie my homies even dated in a clown
suit at a birthday party he went into
class a clown suit all dressed up
playing the part all the whistles you
know everything he could he had on him
you know me smoke bombs and everything
and I'm thinking this is legit you know
I mean he's a real he's a real [__]
you know a magician or whatever he's
doing well it wasn't that what he was
doing was he was getting under the car
and he was releasing something down
there so when the car started and you
took off it wasn't going to stop I don't
know if he cut the brake line or
anything he did but one of my homies was
driving with his old lady and they were
arguing and he turned to the next Lane
went to put the brakes so he could slow
down to go off the off ramp and it never
stopped it went right off the edge of
the freeway and landed on top of
somebody's house luckily he didn't kill
nobody but the reason he did it was
because
how could I put it he was a sucker for a
hole it's my aunt but he was a sucker
for a hole every time she got into a
situation he'd be right there and my
uncle he was like six two he was a
really really big man his wife must have
been like five eight
five nine if that you know what I mean
and that was my uncle Sabu he was
married to my aunt Stella he used to
style a lot on a dope he was like the
main connection there and us being young
we already knew who was coming if
somebody got after her car would relay
the message and so on social my uncle
would get it and whatever my uncle's
looking at it due to this food we were
going to watch but nine times out of ten
he would just give dude more dope and I
told my uncle what would you give this
guy so much dope and he's saying he
loses it every time a person doesn't
lose their dope every [__] day you
know what I mean he's trying to say
losing it so my grandmother will say oh
I'm sorry for your meals here you go and
break them off a couple of hundred he
didn't earn his [__] he didn't go out
there for a nine to five and get it
checked up in the end of the week nah
they got paid in the end of the week but
there was no check stub and that caught
my attention because I said wow if they
could come in here and just write a
check and sign it and just pass it
through well I want to try it I was
going to try it in about two days before
I tried it a girl went in there she
trying to do it for I think 20 grand and
what they did was they said oh here's
your receipt wait right here we got to
go to the back and talk to the manager
well they were going to talk to no
manager they were going back to use the
phone to say that this Rod was extorting
him
and I used to be always careful because
in my hood you can only have so many
points and then they validate you and
you go to validation for the rest of
your life that you're in prison me I
don't promise to ever go back but due to
the fact that I got in trouble a lot and
I was getting in trouble a lot more it
kind of became Destiny you know I mean
it was going to happen it was my uncles
used to school me and tell me look this
is how you do when you're in this is how
you do it now look at him like
why the [__] are you telling me this
what am I doing here what do you mean am
I supposed to be doing he said oh yeah
when you do a driver you get it you lock
it like this you lock it like that you
car can hear you aim it and you fire and
I always go back to the first time I
ever fired on somebody I don't know if I
hit somebody I heard somebody scream but
I mean once you shoot the adrenaline in
your body
just shoots you out fast as [__] I ran
home so [__] fast and the [__] up
part about about it was if I'm standing
in front of my yard and I'm looking down
the street I could see these dudes in
this homies posted on the street and
that belonged to us
so what I did was when my little homies
got out I told him look go over here to
my spot tell my girl you want this and
you want that and she'll give it to you
you guys go handle your business you
know me because the simple fact that I'm
kind of tired of these dudes coming
around here acting like I owe them like
whatever you give me you should give
them and I told them it's not like that
you know you got to work for it you know
what I mean and I used to be out there
working for mine when I was a Youngster
when I was a Youngster mark
I had not a care in the world I didn't
give a [__] about a dude's mom I didn't
even [__] about his grandmother if I
caught him slipping with his aunts well
then I'll try to pull him away and beat
his ass but a lot of times I'm beating
one of the dudes asses and somebody
grabs my hair and [__] pulls it back
and I turn on and punch him and it's a
lady I'm like [__] what the [__] is
wrong with this [__] you know me she's
over here [__] pushing me don't even
know me she don't even know if I'm gonna
shoot around and [__] shoot her ass
you know me she don't even know that but
like I was saying they have so much
balls back in the day that it was
nothing like it is today today it's
totally different you know I see you
guys out there that I know for a fact I
had I had took part in locking this dude
up but yeah he's yelling my name when I
get to the hole it's quiet all the
killers are in there they still yelling
my [__] name oh you burn me you did
this and I'm like man those are some
serious [__] words you know what I
mean now my homie's all upset hope is
this strong finds the Jew use now I tell
them now it's time to whoop homie's ass
for the simple fact that he lied on me
so I didn't whooping his [__] ass
we'll get back in the car and he'd be
like where you want to go
and I always used to tell him take me to
Whittier Boulevard because back then
Whitney Boulevard didn't have
checkpoints you can go up back up back
up back but you couldn't leave and come
back you know he used to stomp your hand
and you're jamming the car and I used to
he used to stand my hand I'll go get
another car and drive that one in there
because at that time they were giving us
25 000 for our truck and I think 35 000
for a car you know what I mean and if I
would have known this Mark if I would
have known this from jump I would have
went and got it to do myself and told
him look I'm the one getting the product
not anybody else these dudes are just
taking the product they're just taking
advantage of it because they're going to
talk you know the guy into giving it up
or doing one just like that you know I
mean and I used to be upset because you
know in my hood we to wear certain
colors we used to have green belts green
hats sometimes even green Levi's you
mean with black shoes and we used to go
and I remember one time we went to
school and we were in there and we must
have been like 20 of us well we're in
the front and we're smoking because you
can smoke outside in the front and I see
one car pass by and the dude's breaking
his neck and I'm like now I might just
be imagining things it might just be the
[__] drugs I'm doing well we're
kicking back again we're drinking a beer
and lo and behold here comes that car
again and I told my Uncle I said hey
this is the third [__] time this car
has came by
get your [__] I'ma get my [__] when they
come back again we're gonna light them
up well what happened was Mark is that
the people were coming and they made a
left turn
and they got caught in the crash fire in
the crossfire it caught him my uncle was
the longest one and it caught him and
caught him back here but all these other
dudes were just laid up they had like a
you know they had some really nice cars
that they used to come with they were
really young I don't know where they got
the cars from but they were really nice
cars and I knew they weren't stolen
because like I had stated before I was
the type of individual that I would yell
at my enemies girlfriends because once I
sleep with them and get their
information well then I knew all world
where all her homeboys kicked it and I
used to go over there and be in my
homies and we'll take turns on me I'd do
my D put it away go and come back and
pass the homies and the home where you
going we're going to [__] old boy
spot to light them up and I'm like I
already been there they're like we don't
care we want them again so they would
get them beat the [__] out of them so
dude was getting beat several times but
my whole thing was if I would have asked
them hey you know
um you know are you doing all right most
people would be like well I'm doing a
little bit you know what I mean and I
said well let's go inside then we'll go
inside his house and he'll have dope
right here dope right here dope right
here all three different kinds and I'm
saying damn you're just giving me 75
worth of that in my mind I'm saying I'm
glad I didn't help him on his last Jam
when he owed fifty thousand dollars he
owed fifty thousand dollars to somebody
and they were on his ass he came to me
into my spot and he was like hey Johnny
can you help me out bro you know what I
mean you you're trying to get me you
know I mean I don't know who they are I
told them I know exactly who they are
through the [__] cartel that's
who wants to [__] get you you're
[__] with their dope I told them I
told you from jump if you're gonna get a
job and you're going to work for these
[__] you got to work
consistently because one day you [__] up
you're you're replaceable I was gonna
say Irreplaceable but you're replaceable
you'll switch your ass up so quick your
head will Spin and then once they kick
you out you know where are you gonna go
you know I mean I mean I'm not going to
go to Peaceful where my cousins are at
where they're kicking in they're doing
their thing I'm not going to go over
there because they're like well shoot me
down you know what I mean they're
they're treasurements they're not a big
gang but they're really really
treacherous you know they bring out a
lot of real [__] in their hood
you know I mean not these fake ass Foods
you see come through here and tell you a
story and it's all [__] because I
listen to several guys that I know on
that channel and
they're talking strictly about nothing
you know what I mean they got you asking
the questions like I told my homie the
other day he said well when I go
um is that is that guy Mark gonna ask me
questions is he gonna ask me you know
what I go Mark don't ask nothing you're
speaking about your life if it's the
truth then you ain't got to worry about
it you ain't you ain't even tried and
convicted of it I said I got convicted
of two counts of kidnap and I could
speak about them freely today because of
the fact that it'll be double jeopardy
you know I mean when I really look into
it I think that they got over on me when
I did my last video because I did my
last video and said he pays you 500 a
video where he gives you 600 just for
yourself and I would explain to him all
the time you know I would tell him it's
not just me I got my girlfriend there
you know me and I got my cousin living
there and you're breaking every window
well this dude was breaking my window so
much that I laid in the cup for his ass
I went and stashed in the bush it was
like 4 30 5 in the morning and I see
three dudes walking up and sure enough
one has one of those biggest red blocks
in his hand before he's about to throw
it I shoot boom I don't know how I did
it but it must have hit the [__]
break because it didn't hit his hand he
hit the brick the brick exploded when
flying he was all pissed off you know
what I mean but that's the way my uncles
used to do their things now these were
my uncles now remember my uncles all had
Brothers these are all my cousins I
think my youngest cousin is doing 18
years right now
he stabbed a dude when the dude was
asleep
why he did that I don't know I I tried
to ask him to ask him on the phone like
why did you shoot this dude when he only
owed you you know a 15 bucks until Nanny
that ain't that serious but I also have
to take into consideration that my drug
you can do it right now and you won't
have to worry about like six in the
evening
with Heroin you do it right now and
about 12 o'clock in the afternoon you
already want lunch you know I mean that
that's what I've been I've been
observing I've been reading up on
because I wanted to know where your
where your channel had came from
you know I mean I listened to your
interview I listened to another a lot of
other people's interviews and I don't
like to be the one that says
um
um this um that because when you do that
it feels to me like you're thinking
about what you're about to say and if
it's the truth well then it's the truth
nobody can change it not even I you know
what I mean this is the truth I gave her
and now I'm trying to tell a lie she
catches me in a lie now she's talking
[__] now I'm walking down the street on
Broadway and an old man walks up to me
and he's only about
about this being and he's like hey man I
heard you were talking about my girl man
saying she was a [__] man and she sold
her ass and all this I said what are you
talking about he's like yeah she told me
that you said she was just using you and
that that that little birds you know she
that she was just using you you know
what I mean and I'm like well I don't
get I don't mind being used and abused
but when you're misused that's a whole
different ball game and I used to see a
lot of my homies getting misused by
other people you know I mean by other
people I'm talking about white people
black people because they used to know
that that corner house you can go there
and either somebody's gonna score you
PCP
uh angel dust
weed or straight cocaine and my uncle
knew how to lock up the cocaine he used
to get it put two ounces in a jar put
some [__] uh put some mint leaves in
there put about a hundred dollars pour
with the Juice mix it all around and
stick it in the freezer
when they first duck it in the freezer I
was like what the [__] are you doing you
know me or you're [__] parking in the
freezer it's gonna [__] me free freeze
he said well that's the best way they do
it you know you sit in there you know I
mean uh uh he said he said like how
could I put it okay but I I I've been
trying to work on my English so that it
would be proper because I'm noticing now
that I'm getting older I would speak
about something but I used a lot of
slang and what I'm trying to do right
now is I'm trying to get the proper
etiquette for English and the propaganda
for Spanish and between both of them
English is much much harder than Spanish
you know what I mean but you'd like to
get some of those guys because some of
those guys from Mexico been through a
lot of [__] I mean they crossed the
river with a [__] plastic bag
in the mouth and swim the river so that
way when they got in the other side they
can get some fresh clothes and get
dressed up as some new attire you know
what I mean I thought that was kind of
appealing to me I was like man I could
go over here do the deed run five blocks
get up on top of that water tower and
they would never see me well one time I
was going to do that and I'm just about
to step out and I hear a footstep move
so I step back there's like seven
[__] cops walking by looking intense
looking everywhere man and me the type
of person I am is if they're gonna get
me I just close my eyes like
you know to be invisible like they won't
see me you know what I mean and I'm like
so I used to try to I used to try to
blend in the crowds but was so [__] up
Mark is that I can try to wear any type
of material any type of clothes but I
still get zeroed out now I've been
trying to figure it out lately lately is
it my style
you see my aura you know I know it's not
fear because I don't really pump fear
into nobody so it has to be one or the
other so the other day when I was asking
for advice they were like yeah you could
put up 200 or you could put a 400 and
you'll get a big old Global make your
money back I go yeah I'm see this is
what you don't understand
if I was to get something it wouldn't I
couldn't give her nothing because
everything I'm getting I'm trying to fix
where we live you know what I mean and
it's it's really really hard because you
know you're living there you're kicking
it you know there's a knock at the door
and there's like five of my homies at
the front door the lady lives right
upstairs so then she started complaining
about who are all those guys you're
bringing over and I tell her they're all
my cousins I got six aunts seven uncles
and they all got children and they're
all for my hood they're all from my hood
you know every single that's one of them
except two you mean and it wasn't really
two that they didn't sleep on the floor
you know man I used to sleep on the
floor somebody's gonna come by and shoot
and shoot you no not in my heart in my
own home [__] that thing and scare me I
said they're not there to scare you
they're there to hurt you they're there
to relay a message
for our uncle through you because they
tried it for me already and I shot him
down I'm not shooting nothing to nobody
for you or anybody else because my life
is always at Jeopardy every time I pick
up I'm a third Striker so I always have
to remember inside I'm a third Striker
and I [__] up and I'm gone they're gonna
take me lock me up put me away forever
you know just recently I was telling you
about that guy that's caught up in me
myself that guy Casper that's caught up
in me you know I've been working on him
a lot
but he's so so powerful what I mean by
that is if I get sick and it's the only
thing there I'm going to grab it and I'm
gonna get high on it for the simple fact
that that's the way the drug makes you
you know it doesn't get you on the phone
it doesn't get you on the floor looking
for rocks no it doesn't do that anything
you find like a piece of pistachio or
anything they stick it in the pipe and
it starts popping
popping everywhere done [__] up the
pipes put over here down the street you
could buy 12 pookies for ten dollars you
know that's a hell of a deal you know I
bought we got those two days ago because
every time someone goes through the spot
and wants to buy some dope they're like
ain't even buy some dope and then the
next thing is hey you got a spoon and
I'm like why do you come up prepared
when you know where you're coming oh
there there might not be what do you
mean there might not be nothing that
guy's here every day man you know me
people are there every day you know what
I mean and due to just want to make
excuses excuses after excuses have
excuses you know mean I had like three
homies that were really dope and each
one of them got shot because of the fact
that they were pulling the wool over the
next person's eyes instead of being in
front with them and telling me look I
got 30 000 I'm gonna give you ten
thousand and see what you could do with
it people think that's a lot of money
you and I know Mark that ten dollars ten
thousand dollars is not a lot of money
you know we blow that [__] in a year
like five ten times I know I do you know
I mean because I'd be buying some nice
stuff you know I mean I bought some
things yesterday that are antiques
they're so [__] nice you know what I
mean and I don't know what it is how I
come along and find them or people give
them to me it's just like they say here
and I see it and I'm like what the [__]
does this person even know what they're
giving me and me then I'm a type I'm the
type of person I'm honest I show them
you know I mean look this is who makes
it this is the type of bear it is it's
not cheap you know what I mean and what
they used to do is they just opened up
the seams on the side take out some of
that [__] that you know the uh the gods
or whatever it is the the cotton and
it's the gun inside and stuff the white
weapons inside it would be cruising we'd
get pulled over and never once did the
[__] cop ever grab the doll if you
would have grabbed the dog he would have
noticed the difference right away but he
never grabbed it so what happened was he
was talking [__] about me saying that I
came over here just for certain things
and all this [__] and all along
all he was doing was coming over here
getting money and then straight to the
connect straight to the connect I'd be
like hey you want to go with me now I
got somewhere to go where you got to go
when you can't mind so in my hand will
say damn I don't want to get to that
point where
I I I uh I get to the point where if
something goes wrong I just hurt
somebody right away I try to put that
guy away I try to put that bad bad
person so far back but yet my uncles and
all my cousins when I see them you know
they don't call me Johnny they call me
by Casper my my nickname they call me by
that and when they call me that I tell
them
because my grandmother's listening you
know what I mean and I don't want my
grandmother to know all my business not
at this time you know what I mean I
don't care keeping it within myself but
once my grandmother got at me and asked
me hey what was wrong I totally
explained it to her expecting an ass
whooping but instead instead she fixed
the whole thing and she said hey you
need to stay jumping on those bedrooms
jumping out that window because me and
my little brother as soon as my
grandmother went to sleep oh we tiptoed
out of her room because she used to have
a seat right next to her but we used to
have to wait until like oh two three in
the morning
just to get out and go have fun
so all the day would be gone more on
house arrest all day but once six
o'clock came and the evening started
we're gone because she can't call no
more probation officers she can't call
no Law Officers to come and get me
because once I see the law I'm gone you
know what I mean they ain't gonna catch
me you know that lady had me coming
lately had me coming across
a lot of guys they've been asking me hey
can I go do a video and I tell them
straight out Mark you have to speak to
mark first and tell him about your lies
and then he decides if he wants to hear
it or not I said because you can imagine
how many years he hears a day I see when
I go I try to take something different
every time that way I could keep him
listening keep him on the edge of the
seat and just listening intently that's
my thing I want somebody to be at the
edge of the seat like [__] that really
happened yeah that really happened you
know I mean oh not didn't happen that's
[__] and about 10 minutes later the
same thing happened again you know what
I mean and these Foods would feel like
idiots I mean there's been times Mark
right now where I was sharing with you
that I'm getting gang stalked you know
what I mean and I never knew what a gang
stalker was until I came face to face
with these [__] now these fools
look Gangnam straight gang member but
yet they're against gang members they're
against them all the way you know I mean
and they should they already killed two
of my homies
these dudes from Norwalk
um what is it normal
Tweakers I think they call them and
these dudes are up all night searching
for people to get caught slipping and
the reason they're catching people is
because remember they're up all night
we're not we're asleep so once we get up
and we hear the gunfire we get our
things we run out there and shoot
whoever is but they're long gone
so I said well you know what since
they're coming right here and they have
to turn up that hill up on the up on the
top of the hill he lives droopy and God
thought they live on the top of the hill
if they sell the shooting down here all
they got to do is come outside and light
up the car that goes by
but they're so so greedy today they're
so greedy they're so naive they act like
everything belongs to them everything
you know my homies think everything they
get if we're hitting something and
there's a lot of good [__] I'll grab
something and I'll put over here and
then my homie will grab it and put it
back where his shit's at now tell me
what the [__] are you doing dog it took
me a while to get a while to get his
[__] wires off now I wonder because
I'm taking fridge and everything fridge
I'm taking microwave I'm taking a
[__] the freezer I'm taking it off
for the simple fact that you know
uh
when I went to go take something from
somebody's house I wanted to leave a
butthole bear I don't even want him to
have toilet paper you know what I mean
and the smartest thing I ever did was I
ran in a U-Haul truck backed it in and
just loaded everything up I think two
people in the neighbors came by here
where so-and-so going and we say I was
going on vacation they'll be gone for a
while and they were like oh I had
something to tell her about she's gone
she ain't coming back for a while you
know what I mean and when my grandmother
goes to Mexico you know she knows so
many people up there that she would
bring us back cartons of cigarettes now
they tasted nasty but they were still
written marble on top of them you know I
mean she used to bring that she used to
bring BB guns for us she used to bring
some different kind of Mexican candies
all kinds of cookies all kinds of [__]
well I was a you know well she used to
just buy them for everyone but she used
to have to put a lock on the
refrigerator they had a righteous knock
on our refrigerator the one in the front
and one in the back and we wanted to eat
we had to have my grandmother come and
unlock the [__] with the keys so we can
eat that's where I found out that that
my cousin knowing that she uh she used
to take care of that wasn't too smart
that she was kind of off
because she was my cousin and she was
trying to get at me and I was telling
her hey you're my [__] cousin what
the [__] is wrong with you you know I
mean why would you want to get at me I
want to sleep with me when you're my
blood you know I mean I don't care when
I was in placement I used to do the same
thing I had a boyfriend in there and I
used to be with him and I said well
that's why you never ever
uh finish that program because a lot of
times when we're out here and say they
want to give us a program they'll put us
right down the street
to that big ass [__] building right
there where all the Parolees and
everything live and put you in there and
I went in there voluntarily so I can
leave anytime I want that's what I
thought nah they would keep me there
till 1 30 and then the next one oh
there's another Cinema
coming up you know someone's gonna do
one and I'm not saying I'm any better
than the ones they do but to me more
because those are boring they're [__]
it's boring they're talking about the
same thing over and over and over about
how many people they shot how many
people they ran over with the bus you
know how many cars have they stolen you
know how many bikes have they took
humans just recently I was on Maple
about three days ago and I had a really
really nice bike
and I fell asleep with my arm tucked
inside the spokes can you believe that
they took my arm out and then rolled my
bike off but when they rolled my bike
off
I already had knew there was there was
something wrong because homie that does
business with him
kept on getting upset it kept on telling
me nothing was happening then I would
come get over here to you and say hey
what's up you know yeah it's happening
and I'm like what is it are they jealous
why are they jealous when they have the
same opportunity to speak to Mark like I
do the only difference I notice is when
you do interviews with other people
you're throwing in their question after
question you know I mean and I'm like
you know what what
why is it so hard for them to explain a
story that is true you know I mean that
is honestly true like when they get up
here and I say I don't speak about
nobody no names no organizations nobody
in particular who want to speak about my
cousins I go to my cousins and the next
cousin I talk about is is my cousin they
call Sabu I think I spoke about
my next cousin after him is my cousin
negro now he's the type of individual
that
he used to be with a lot of women I'm
talking multiples of women I'm talking
about the phone to ring off the hook for
him my grandmother would get mad he'd
come home different with a different
woman every night every night and I'd be
like man where the [__] does he get
these women so I had to ask him you know
hey
I talked to the homie Ram now I'm gonna
ask you what is your guys's secret how
do you guys get to talk to so many women
take them out end up marrying them what
are you telling them and they told me
lies
we're telling we're telling them lies
you know like what kind of Lies he said
we'll turn them lines we're telling them
we got money this is our truck you know
this is our stuff we live here you know
and they would totally lie
and then when the time would come and
the lady would come out the house and
get the [__] get off my property no my
homies would feel like [__] now the
broads know they're lying so who gets
them next me and my little homies
because they're like oh [__] these older
dudes these younger dudes got more [__]
going on so and we did we did have more
[__] going on I mean we slang everything
Mark there's not one drug that I haven't
sold except like cannabinol or Reds or
your whites I even sold whites I was in
junior high selling whites you know what
I mean I was in I was in junior high
selling wines I was in in a high school
selling weed and marijuana and I had the
best you know I'm sorry Coke and
marijuana I had the best Coke anywhere
the kind of [__] you would very touch
your tongue and your whole [__] mouth
would get numb and my connection was
some 15 year old advice on his dad was a
connection but I used to kick it with
him every day one time he took me to
into his dad's room and we went inside
there and the whole closet was just
filled with nothing but weed and cocaine
and he grabs a [__] bag of weed he
Scoops in there and puts it in a baggie
he grabs the weave Scoops it in there
puts it in another baggie we Jam boom We
jam now we're in the hood and we're
slinging left and right and there goes
the homies again getting jealous and
what do I get what do I get see at that
time I didn't use heroin so I didn't
know how bad it really was I didn't know
that it made you so sick where you
didn't want to eat right now I got a
lunch and I ate and it was all right but
due to the fact that my body's lacking
and what I've been giving it you get a
lot of pain I'm saying if I was to stop
right now and tell you hey Mark I'ma
stop I'm done I ain't using drugs no
more
I say within three days I'd be in the
hospital either with my labor going bad
my kidneys going bad something would be
wrong with me that's what I noticed with
these drugs I think the last time I've
had a cold Mark was like
[__] uh four years ago man I haven't
been sick for four years at all and I'm
trying to read it up I'm trying to read
up on on on the fentanyl like what does
it do to a person you know fentanyl has
long periods of time that things happen
like you know uh you catch something it
doesn't heal for that [__] for the
longest now before I heard that's
because people had
AIDS or people who had HIV that they
used to get
scams on their skin and that's how it
started I ran into why boys and white
girls they got their whole face just
picked out
picked out bad you know and they're
still right there talking about hey is
there anything in there and all it is is
blood but they're telling me no that's a
bug so they would dig and dig and dig my
homie dug all the way almost to the
bones of his leg his skin he took it off
little by little by little and what it
was it was all dead skin but he would
pull out the other skin too do it over
and over it took like about a month and
a half when I seen him wearing shorts
and I was like hey
what happened to that stuff you had I
don't know if it's called MRSA
or some type of allergy um allergy
eating bacteria you don't mean it ain't
bacteria and Allergy you know I mean but
I remember one Christmas my grandmother
went and she bought me an aquarium
and it was like 30 fish in there and I
had my fish I was a little kid I love my
fish but after a while I started
noticing that my fish were missing and
I'm like what the [__] what happened to
my damn fish well my uncle what he was
doing was he got his own aquarium and he
was stealing my fish and taking him his
room and putting them in his fish tank
so I was like well how can they get
eaten with them what I did when I
[__] punctured a hole in the side of
his [__] plastic thing and it
squirted all over his bed all over the
floor and the smell didn't come out like
fish for a long ass time but like I said
I wasn't a cold man I didn't do that
just to do that because I wanted to do
it I did it because I felt it was the
right thing to do because my uncle was
the loudest the the youngest brother and
he found he kind of felt the obligation
that he was supposed to take care of me
and my little brother but I had that
covered I had that covered all the way
up to the point where my little brother
just lost it he said I don't want you no
more I don't need you no more you don't
gotta help me business no more you know
meaningless I don't care if you have
money I don't want no money and my
little brother he stays with money he's
what you call a baller just the other
day I was singing and some dude asked me
hey you got any aspirin and I was like
no matter of fact I don't man I don't
take but aspirin he said well we are a
damn look and we should say it was a
woman [__] you [__] [__] the uh the
aspirin give them to me and he [__]
flicks the dollar at me and I [__]
grab it I put it away next time I
[__] don't come around me asking for
something you know what I mean if it's
there you get all upset you know what I
mean what's up with that you know I mean
because there's a lot of guys out here
that they actually feel like they got
something coming like through about
something and I see them peeling in
[__] pants mark on a little ass
[__] dude like this you know what I
mean I couldn't share that stuff with
you because you got all these dudes that
come over here that I'm watching and
they're all talking a good one you have
this and this is this and that then they
get in front of a camera and they freeze
up and me I don't freeze up you my thing
is I'm telling a story that is true from
the heart none of my [__] is made up you
know and all those people that give me
comments and tell me hey Johnny the
stuff you say man I catch on to it you
know I mean please don't stop you know
keep going and I tell them hey it's
completely up to my photographer which
you can read about him
in White on your belly and he has a
phone number hey call him get out of
what you want me to do your footwork for
you you want me to tell you more this
guy's coming and then bring you and I
know you don't give me [__] but yet I
bring you over here that has happened to
me so many times besides you know some
girls that I bring you know they do a
good job some dude to do a good job but
I try to explain to him and tell him
you're not in there trying to create
like a movie you're in there trying to
you know I mean do the right thing and
give a message to these young kids out
there that really need guidance you know
what I mean I mean it's 13 year olds
right here in Skid Row 13 years old they
do look like a [__] little kid and
they were slapping them there were some
dudes that were just slapping them back
and forth so I stopped them I told him
what the [__] you doing bro I worked out
my [__] knife I was like what the
[__] you doing man all these little
youngster said this and said that I said
man how old are you man oh I'm 16 you're
gonna be 17 I said 16. what the [__] are
you doing down here
there's not supposed to be no room for
those 16 year olds just recently I see
the lady come out of the tent with two
little babies
I'm pretty sure that's against the law
I'm pretty sure you can't have your
children on the streets leaving you with
you in a tent what your old man's
smoking dope that ain't gonna happen I
know that Mark for a fact you know what
I mean but I've also seen it I've also
went inside well I'm kicking it with him
inside their [__] tent
and they're smoking weed in PCP and the
baby is Right awake and all the smoke is
going through the baby and I'm like hey
dog
your daughter your son's inhaling that
[__] only nothing gonna happen ugly
you're [__] out your mind just
recently a [__] cop touched it in a
[__] OD you know I imagine bringing
it in all inside your lungs you're gonna
OD quicker than a [__] you know
what I mean you mean all my uncles use
one thing my uncle needle used weed and
cocaine and heroin my uncle chivo he
used heroin but he used to Jack every
[__] thing we had in our house if you
bought a brand new radio he'll get in
there and he'll Jack it he'll wait you
need it and he would come and take it
well knowing that it's his knowing that
he did it you know and then the
following day he'd come back and he'd
take some of my grandmother's coins in
her jewelry at first they were blaming
it on me saying that I was the one
taking it I was like [__] that I'm gonna
go find this [__] I'm gonna put
him in his place so I'll go to the park
and find him when I found them him and
my homie were arguing and my homie got
one of those sticks with the nail on the
end and just stabbed him uh
you know what I mean so he pulled it out
he ran down the street seen some cops
went up to the cop and stand in the side
of the neck now they locked everything
down they locked everything down to
fight this individual and that was only
a couple weeks
one time they had it knocked down for a
whole month
and I know they were watching because
you don't mean they just pull up
Park and now the soul gets out of the
car no one gets out of the car that
means they're watching just the other
day I was at 7-Eleven way over there on
uh Olympic and I walked all the way back
and halfway to my house there's a
hamburger stand it's so good excellent
food I forgot the name of it Farmer
John's or something something like that
they served some excellent excellent
food and I went in there and I was in
there eating and the door goes bing bing
and I look up boom and it's those
[__] they've been sitting
outside for me for like a whole 45
minutes now I'm unaware of what the [__]
they want
what if they're jealous whether I did
one of their homies back dirty back in
the day I'm not too sure but everywhere
I go
you know what I mean and and I'm gonna
watch your video or something I plug it
in and show somebody or trying to the
phone I always have somebody criticizing
it oh man you didn't do that now let's
go to My Hood and ask my homies we could
bet a hundred dollars right now who did
what I said because I'm not like you
when the [__] gets thick you guys get
running I seen that yesterday
first hand I couldn't believe it and
then it's not like they outnumbered us
we are numbered then but my homie just
gave it away like nothing like it was
candy here you go you know what I mean
and that [__] really pisses me off
because I'm out here busting my ass mark
taking prison chances every [__] time
I say something to somebody I'm taking
prison chances and I constantly take
them over and over and over I ask myself
are you going crazy are you just playing
stupid you know what I mean because
I don't have nothing to show for what I
did right here except the spot my car
stuff like that that's when I got the
show and I love it you know I mean other
people come in and say man I hated that
[__] man [__] that [__] and I tell the
reason that was is because you don't
know how to speak to a crowd of people
you don't know how to get a story across
I said I'm getting this story across and
letting the children out there know this
ain't the lifestyle it may look good on
TV it may look on gangster movies on CSI
whatever they made me look good on any
channel but it's totally different from
what they portray
they portray one way and it's really
another way you know what I mean and I
noticed that because you can have a guy
right here uh a band singing every
[__] song they know but now one of
them has one [__] tattoo but then on
the other side you run into the homies
and they play a tune and they play every
[__] tune you know what I mean and I
tell them you got potential man you got
potential you don't gotta be a gang
member how are you supposed to go get
jumped in at 38 years old
what happened to those other 20. well lo
and behold I find out why this [__]
wanted that much money because she
bought that off dude that because it
didn't fit her little she stopped me
right now and she's like hey you got
that thing and I'm like yeah I got one
she's okay you go to my house with me
and take it I'm like for what
she's all this [__] dude pushed my
little girl out the way and I'm a Papa
Cap in his ass and I'm like yeah right
you're a woman you ain't gonna do [__]
[__] when we pulled up to that
[__] party
she let my homie drive and her and my
homie were on a shotgun seat and a
passenger seat with two shotguns and let
them off in broad daylight broad
daylight two in the afternoon
I knew that those food would never never
forget that [__] because I went by the
school was closed nobody was going and I
was like damn then they started blaming
it on me because me and my cousin look
alike everything I do they blame him
everything he does they blame me and
it's [__] up because
I'm only I'm only here Mark to try to
help to use understand that being a gang
member ain't all what is wrapped up to
be several times I've told them
it looks good it smells good but it's
not good you know what I mean uh mainly
any new nestovers here never once have I
seen them come to the door with a whole
pizza and be like hey here's a piece for
you here's a piece for you but yeah
they're rather nickel and dime you you
know what I mean and whenever I come
Mark I come because I have a bill to
take care of you know what I'm saying
and I want to get out there and push a
message I'm trying to get a message to
people that is not too long so I won't
lose my listener I'm trying to get a
lesson to them more you have to watch
your back out here it's get raw it's
nothing nice people take it for granted
you know you got [__] you're
riding your bike and all of a sudden you
hear somebody yelling hey that's my
[__] butt you know look at him one
time check this out man that's the
oldest [__] rule in the book man
that's the only stage people been doing
man talking about hey that's my bike man
let me get my [__] bike it'd be that
you're new you're like hey I I didn't
know I got it from my homie here you go
and then I get back at my homies black
dude never gave me no [__] bike
you know I'm like oh man this
[__] I can't wait till I catch
him it's so hard to [__] catch him
because they're hiding in a [__] tent
you got Foods in the tent they've been
in there for [__] two weeks and never
come out only come out pissed in a
bottle and put it on the side that's how
lazy [__] are these days there
is no more gangsters Mark there's no
more Charles there's no more solid-ass
[__] you don't see them no more
you know what I mean like I said before
you used to be able to spot a cholo now
you see this young white boy walking
down the street and he's talking about
where you from I said
what the [__] I just tell him where the
[__] are you from you know I mean you're
the white boy not me where are you from
and they would tell me and I'll tell
them oh man you ain't gonna last in this
game you're not gonna last in this game
you don't have the heart you don't have
the [__] heart to see things done to
people and not feel bad about it before
I was a bad person more like I didn't
feel bad about [__] I'd heard a
[__] and I wouldn't even give a
[__] I'm gonna talk to it about my
homies and we'll laugh and do the
critical condition ready to die but
we'll ask about it because we want him
to die you know every time my homies die
every one of my homies that died I got a
phone call and they told me and I
couldn't believe it and I had to pinch
myself like nah you know what I mean but
they'll tell the next person that the
next person to tell the next person then
the next thing you know is blown up out
of proportion you know I mean that's why
I come up here and I try to talk
specifically about me my family and the
way we do things you know I mean I
didn't want to take up too much of your
time this time off because I know that
you're very busy man you know I have
some other ones for you but like I
always tell you I want to get a beer and
tell the truth but I also want to get up
here and tell the truth and not get
arrested when I walk out that door you
know what I mean I want to say hey these
are all just fictional lies you know I'm
telling you [__] but really you
don't do reality Mark they're all real
none of them are fake none of them at
all I've lived every one of them I've
been through every aspect that I have
told you about I've been through all of
them I've been rubbed together so tight
than I thought that was it this is the
end of my life and it wasn't my fault it
was the other motherfucker's fault but
being that we're doing it together the
guy up top don't want to hear hey my dog
ate three of your grams he'd be like
well you better go through your dog [__]
and find it you know what I mean you're
out of food stamp oh man I lost the
clavo I was being with some broad man
and I fell asleep man and she got me and
I'm like that's the oldest [__] trick
in the book a [__] will take you sleep
with you when you fall asleep you'll be
lucky even if you wake up with your
pants cause nowadays they ain't going
through your [__] they're just snatching
all your [__] at one time
and then you know when they got [__]
like I told my hungry let me see what
you got let me see what you got what do
you got
the [__] had like five pairs of pants
of mines and like four shirts she don't
want to show me until I picked them up
and I looked at them and they were
marked and I was like this is my [__]
shirt this is my shirt these are my
pants what do you get this [__] at
there's only one way you can get it if
you're going inside my van and they deny
it left and right but I found some
makeup and I didn't belong to Dana and I
was like oh yeah somebody else was in
here you know what I mean so you know
they get in there just recently a dude
was breaking into the car and they shot
him dead in the head he hadn't even gone
in the car yet he was barely putting the
slim jim in and they shot him in the
back of the head just because he was
trying to steal the car you know that's
really really Petty I could just imagine
if I have a gang of drugs on me and they
know I got them and I start running
a lot of times I don't want to run
because the last time I ran the sex
basically canine canines on me and oh
those [__] are no joke Mark
those [__] aren't so bad they bite
and they don't let go they rip and rip
and rip you know what I mean and it
hurts so [__] bad you know what I
mean I want to get another dog but I'm
trying to think of what kind of dog to
get I don't want no big ass pit bull
where everybody's afraid of it
I want something more like a like a like
a like a terrier like an English terrier
something that sticks out something you
can room take care of you know because
right now I only have me I really ain't
taking care of anybody my last little
girl turned 18 or a year ago so I'm not
obligated to any women anybody any own
anybody amount of money the only
obligation that I have is to make sure
that my homies are right or they're
nearly dope because a lot of [__]
they're doing is crooked you know what I
mean it will catch up to them you know I
relay these messages Mark and I want to
relay more but I know you ain't got much
time but I wanted to give you something
today tell you a little bit of my but
about about my family about the way they
are so everybody gets the input on me
how I was and I speak up about my family
and those are just a couple I speak
about there's many many more but the
things that the things I have to go
through my
you know the the back files in my mind
and remember oh [__] this is what my
uncle did this is what my uncle did and
I never mentioned their names but like I
stated before
people have the right to be whoever they
want to be but when you grow up and it's
the second generation and there's four
before you and five in front of you when
you're in the middle that's all what
you're destined to be
is a gangster and that's all I want to
be I don't want to be anything else I
love the thrill of walking down the
street and the people talking get on the
other side of the street I love this I
love it because that means I can stay
away from them more and see them less
you know what I mean what that's just a
little something for you Mark is that
cool excellent Johnny you know I've
always got one for you mark